>> Katie: THE LEFT NOT JUST
CALLING FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM, THEY NOW WANT TO DEFUND
THE POLICE AFTER TWO NYPD
OFFICERS WERE SHOT AND ANOTHER
WAS STABBED LAST NIGHT WHILE
PROTECTING AGAINST LOOTING.
THIS NEW PUSH GAINING SUPPORT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY INCLUDING
FROM FORMER HILLARY CLINTON
PRESS SECRETARY.
>> IS OUR NATION BEING RIPPED
APART BY A TOTAL AND COMPLETE
LIE, APPROVABLE LIE.
OF THE 802 SHOOTINGS IN WHICH
THE RACE OF THE POLICE OFFICER
AND TEST SUSPECT WAS NOTED, 371
OF THOSE KILLED WERE WHITE, 236
WERE BLACK, THE VAST MAJORITY
WERE ARMED AND OVERALL THERE
WERE A TOTAL OF PRECISELY TEN
CASES IN THE UNITED STATES LAST
YEAR IN WHICH UNARMED
AFRICAN-AMERICANS WERE FATALLY
SHOT BY THE POLICE.
IN FULLY HALF, THE OFFICER WAS
CRIMINALLY CHARGED.
IS IT POSSIBLE THAT MORE OF
THESE OFFICERS SHOULD HAVE BEEN
CHARGED?
JUSTICE IS NOT ALWAYS SERVED,
THAT’S FOR SURE BUT EITHER WAY,
THIS IS A VERY SMALL NUMBER IN A
COUNTRY OF 325 MILLION PEOPLE,
THIS IS NOT, NOT EVEN CLOSE TO,
IT IS LAUGHABLE TO SUGGEST IT
IS.
THE NUMBER OF POLICE KILLINGS IS
DROPPING, NO AMERICAN SHOULD
EVER BE MISTREATED BY THOSE IN
AUTHORITY, MUCH LESS KILLED.
>> Katie: SO LAWRENCE, IS
THERE A DANGER HERE IN THIS
NARRATIVE THAT ALL POLICE SHOULD
BE DEFUNDED?
WE KNOW WHEN POLICING STOPS AND
CRIME-RIDDEN COMMUNITIES, THE
PEOPLE WHO SUFFER THE MOST ARE
THOSE WHO HAVE NO DEFENSE
AGAINST THE CRIMINALS.
>> Lawrence: SO LET ME PUSH
BACK A A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE I
THINK THIS SO OFTEN HAPPENS WHEN
WE ARE HAVING THESE DEBATES AND
THIS IS ALL CENTERED AROUND THE
ONE TERM, SYSTEMATIC RACISM.
BECAUSE WE AREN’T ON THE GROUND
AND I MEAN REPUBLICANS ON THE
GROUND, WE TALKED ABOUT THIS A
LITTLE ON THE SHOW, WE ARE
ALWAYS ON DEFENSE WHEN IT COMES
TO THE ISSUES THAT THE LEFT TALK
ABOUT.
SO FOR EXAMPLE, THE ISSUE IS NOT
JUST POLICE SHOOTINGS, IT’S
ABOUT YOU KNOW, WHAT HAPPENS ON
THE GROUND AND THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT SO WITH THE FERGUSON
REPORT YOU SAW THAT IT WAS BIG
GOVERNMENT AND THERE AND THEY
LITERALLY POLICING FOR PROFIT,
WHEN YOU LOOK AT MINNEAPOLIS,
YOU SEE IN THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT, THE USE OF FORCE
THAT WHEN IT COMES TO BLACK
AMERICANS IT’S A BIG PROBLEM
THERE SO INSTEAD OF PEOPLE ON
THE RIGHT SAYING, YOU KNOW WHAT,
THIS IS OUR PLAN.
TO GET RID OF THE UNIONS AND PUT
OUR POLICIES IN THERE.
WHEN PEOPLE SAY SYSTEMATIC
RACISM, INSTEAD OF BEING ON THE
GROUND AND SAYING YOU KNOW WHAT,
PEOPLE SHOULD NOT HAVE TO GO TO
THE SCHOOL JUST BECAUSE THEY
LIVE IN THE ZIP CODE.
WHEN PEOPLE SAY THEY ARE NOT
SAFE IN THE COMMUNITY, INSTEAD
OF GOING INTO THE COMMUNITY, YOU
KNOW IT, THIS IS HOW YOU DEFEND
YOURSELF, THESE ARE YOUR RIGHTS,
THERE IS AN ANSWER FOR EVERY
SINGLE THING THAT BECAUSE
CONSERVATIVES ON A LOCAL LEVEL,
NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT’S NATIONAL POLICY,
LOCAL LEVEL, HOW YOU GET THINGS
DONE, WE NEVER HAVE A RESPONSE
SO WE GO BACK AND FORTH ON WHO’S
THE BIGGER RACIST AND WHO’S NOT.
>> Katie: YEAH.
GREG, YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
DEFUND THE POLICE MOVEMENT?
>> Greg: OBVIOUSLY THAT’S
BIGGER THAN JUST STRUCTURAL
RACISM, ONCE YOU REMOVE THE
POLICE THERE ARE NO PROTECTIONS
AT ALL EVEN FOR MINORITY
NEIGHBORHOODS AND THE POLICE
EXIST TO PROTECT US FROM
OURSELVES, RIGHT?
WITHOUT THEM, YOU HAVE MAD MAX
BEYOND THUNDERDOME BUT THE THING
THAT DAMAGES A LOT OF THESE
ARGUMENTS AND STATISTICS.
WHITE OFFICERS ARE LESS LIKELY
TO SHOOT NONWHITE PEOPLE THAN
NONWHITE OFFICERS SHOOTING
NONWHITE SUSPECTS, I HOPE I GOT
THAT RIGHT.
WHITE OFFICERS ARE LESS LIKELY
TO SHOOT NONWHITE THAN NONWHITE
SHOOT NONWHITE SO IF THE POLICE
IS STRUCTURALLY RACIST IT’S
INTRAMURAL HE RACIST SO THAT’S
NOT A BLACK PROBLEM, IT’S OUR
PROBLEM.
IT’S A SMALL NUMBER BUT THE FACT
THAT NONWHITE OFFICERS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO SHOOT NONWHITE
SUSPECTS THAN WHITE SUSPECTS,
THAT KIND OF DESTROYS THE RACIAL
NARRATIVE, MEANWHILE POLICE
OFFICERS ARE 18 AND A HALF TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO BE KILLED BY A
BLACK MALE THAN AN UNARMED BLACK
MALE IS TO BE KILLED BY A COP
AND THAT’S NOT SAYING THAT THE
LATTER IS NOT A BIG DEAL BECAUSE
IT IS BUT ONCE YOU GET INTO THE
STATISTICS IF I CAN PRONOUNCE
THAT WORD, WHAT YOU FIND IS THAT
THE EMOTIONS ARE REAL BUT
UNTETHERED, SOME VERY
UNCOMFORTABLE FACTS THAT WE WISH
TO IGNORE.
>> Lawrence:>> Katie: I WENT DOW
WASHINGTON D.C., THERE WERE LOTS
OF PROTESTERS THEY ARE LAYING IN
THE STREETS AND LOTS OF POLICE
THERE WHO WERE BLACK POLICE
OFFICERS SO THE QUESTION IS,
DOES DEFUND THE POLICE ALSO
APPLY TO THEM?
>> Dana: APPARENTLY, HE DIDN’T
LEAVE ANY ROOM FOR NUANCE.
REPUBLICAN SHOULD BE SO LUCKILY
OF PROGRESSIVES AND DEMOCRATS
WANT TO PICK THIS UP AS THEIR
MANTLE AND MAKE THIS THEIR
ELECTION MODEL GOING INTO 2020.
BUT I DO THINK THERE IS ROOM
HERE FOR SOME COMPROMISE AND
MAYBE EVEN SOME BIPARTISAN
AGREEMENT BECAUSE I’VE BEEN
LEARNING A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
CONCERNS FROM BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE ABOUT POLICE UNIONS.
THAT MIGHT BE SOMETHING THAT YOU
CAN FIND SOME AGREEMENT AND YOU
CAN LOOK, WHEN YOU SAY YOU WANT
TO DO SOMETHING SPECIFIC AND
JUSTICE FOR GEORGE FLOYD FOR HIS
DEATH TO HAVE MEANT SOMETHING
FOR CHANGE, THE OTHER THING I
WANT TO POINT OUT TO EVERYBODY
BUT MAY BE TO THE LEFT IS IF YOU
REALLY CARE ABOUT REFUGEES WHO
ARE DESPERATE TO COME INTO
AMERICA, WHAT’S THE NUMBER ONE
REASON THEY WANT TO COME TO
AMERICA?
IT’S NOT JUST BECAUSE THEY THINK
THEY’LL GET A JOB, IT’S BECAUSE
THEY ARE FLEEING THE VIOLENCE IN
THEIR OWN COUNTRIES WHERE THE
POLICE AND THE GOVERNMENT CANNOT
PROTECT THEM, THAT’S WHY THEY
WANT TO COME HERE.
IF YOU HAVE SAFETY AND
OPPORTUNITY YOU CAN ACHIEVE
SOMETHING.
>> Katie: DOESN’T NEED TO BE
SOME KIND OF A BALANCE BETWEEN
POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY, THEY
SHOULD BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
BAD BEHAVIOR BUT NOT GOING SO
FAR AS TO PUT COMMUNITIES THAT
NEED POLICING IN JEOPARDY FOR
FUTURE CRIMES.
>> Juan: I THINK THIS IS A BAD
IDEA, DEFUND THE POLICE, TO ME
IT’S POOR COMMUNITIES THAT NEED
HIGHER LEVELS OF ATTENTION AND
ENGAGEMENT FROM THE POLICE TO
PRODUCE GOOD POLICING, TO MAKE
PEOPLE FEEL SAFE IN THEIR HOMES
AND IN TERMS OF THEIR STORES,
PROPERTY, AND THE REST SO I
THINK IN FACT YOU NEED GOOD
POLICING.
TALKING ABOUT DOING AWAY WITH
SOME OF THE DELIVERY OF TANKS
AND MILITARY EQUIPMENT AFTER
WARS, THAT I THINK THEY COULD DO
AWAY WITH BUT I WANT TO SPEAK
FOR A SECOND TO THE IDEA OF THE
STATISTICS BECAUSE IT’S CLEAR
FROM THE STATISTICS I SEE THAT
HALF THE PEOPLE WHO DIE FROM
POLICE SHOOTINGS ARE WHITE BUT
REMEMBER, BLACKS ARE ONLY 13% OF
THE POPULATION AND ACCORDING TO
THESE NUMBERS BLACK PEOPLE ARE
KILLED AT TWICE OUR RATE OF
WHITE PEOPLE BY POLICE AND IN
FACT IT’S NOT ONLY THAT, THEY
ARE TWICE AS LIKELY TO BE
UNARMED SO I AGAIN, TO COME BACK
TO LAWRENCE’S POINT, I THINK
THERE’S MORE ENGAGEMENT AND IT’S
NOT ALWAYS ON A POSITIVE NATURE,
LEAVES PEOPLE FEELING LIKE THE
POLICE MAY BE AN OCCUPYING FORCE
AND WE DON’T WANT THAT.
>> Greg: I JUST WANT TO TACK
ON TILL WANTS THE STATISTIC
WHICH IS, PEOPLE CAN GO AND
CHECK THIS, I BELIEVE YOU ARE
LOOKING AT POPULATION AND NOT
LOOKING AT POLICE ENCOUNTERS.